hast du einen freund eine freund ich
denke mal eine freundin soll das heißen
und wenn du eine hättest würdest du sie
in die öffentlichkeit stellen
leute was geht ab hier soll cani und
heute gibt es mal wieder einen kleinen
block ist ja relativ üblich in letzter
zeit und japan meine familie da wir
haben noch kaffee getrunken ich wo der
erst 18 jahre alt auf jeden fall vielen
dank an alle leute die da gratuliert
haben und da ich jetzt bei meinem tat
bin habe ich hier keinen pc mit dem ich
aufnehmen kann also mach mal wieder in
wieder getan wieder so ein ganz
klassisches frage antwort video und da
werde ich jetzt mit anfangen
frage von marie brenner hersteller ich
fragte hast du einen freund eine freund
ich denke mal eine freundin soll das
heißen
und wenn du eine hättest würdest du sie
in die öffentlichkeit stellen
das relativ gute frage weil es ist ja
echt schon irgendwie kompliziert weil
ich habe das so gesehen bei manchem
anderen youtuber dass da irgendwelche
leute plötzlich beurteilen anhand der
instagram bilder oder sowas wie gut die
leute zueinander passen was sie einfach
nur für komplett lächerlich halte weil
man selbst bei uns youtube ist es ja
auch nur ein teil der so zeigen wie wir
drauf sind beim besten willen nicht
alles und es recht kann man keine leute
anhand von instagram profilen beurteilen
wie gut sich zusammen passen und es ist
auch verdammt 30 wenn man das macht er
bei einer beziehung
andererseits ist es halt auch irgendwie
belastend für die beziehung ich habe es
selbst keine ist aber lassen für die
beziehung wenn man das online stellt
also wenn beziehungsweise habe ich
gesagt wenn man es nicht online stellt
weil irgendwie das ja auch komisch wenn
man halt irgendwie das ja eigentlich
immer so wenn man ab einer bestimmten
größe gibt halt irgendwelche leute die
so fern was den immer streiten us so
hübsch
sonst was sie ist so sexy oder sowas
gefragt bei mädchen ist es ja krass wie
die teilweise reduziert werden auch
aussehen
und da ich denke das ist fast
belastender wenn man wenn es nicht
bekannt ist dass man freude hat als oder
einem partner hat als wenn man es nicht
sagt also ich weiss nicht hatte damals
ja von einem jahr oder so was hatte ich
mal eine freundin hab ich so gehalten
ich habe gesagt ich habe eine freundin
aber halt nicht ja gesagt habe keine
videos mit ihr gemacht und es wurde auch
niemand wäre es aber ich hatte eine
freundin und so dass die leute halt
wissen dass sie ruhig ein bisschen
anstand achten soll also falls sie
welche haben aber andererseits auch
nicht irgendwie so jemand zum helden
haben oder so was so will ich das
wahrscheinlich halten
wenn ich eine freundin hätte also ich
weiß es aber auch nichts muss man
einfach der situation nach entscheiden
also man kann glaube ich also es hängt
auch von der person ab also von von
partnern wie ein medientauglich oder so
ist also wie kritikfähig und sonst was
ja aber das auf jeden fall echten gut
frage habe ich auch schon wieder ewig
darüber geredet wenn sich entscheidend
ist dass deutschland mit deinem jetzigen
freundin oder amerika ohne deine
jetzigen freunde interessante frage von
dass wesley
ich würde in deutschland bleiben also
ich war noch nie in amerika ich stellte
mir vor aber ich will niemals jetzt
meine ganzen freunde aufgeben weil ich
ja wirklich viele leute die ich selber
gerne mag und bei denen ich mich
entweder fühle und ich meine deutschland
ist kein schlechtes land das kann beim
westen wenig sagen wir es immer
irgendwie abgesichert und sowas und es
kommt gerade über wenn man sich diese
ganzen ll sonstwas wie dogs von den
jungs ist unterwegs war anschaut wie
mies sein da gehen kann und insofern
würde ich auf jeden fall in deutschland
bleiben mit meinen leuten also keine
frage bist du dein geburtstag mit der
hashtag kran amina vielleicht auf dem
video day also in berlin da bin ich
nämlich jetzt dieses brauchen eine könnt
ihr auch dem motto beim checken oder
sowas welchem für anzutreffen sein
ich feiere meinen geburtstag gerne mit
euch nach wenn ihr das machen wollt ihr
können spontane video der übernahme
machen und dann machen wir das was hast
du deine ziele erreicht die du bist
heute erreichen wolltest ich musste
eigentlich bin ich sehr zufrieden wenn
mein leben weil ich mein es geht schon
eine menge ab muss ich sagen also ich
hab das völlig zufrieden ich habe viele
freunde und so und erlebe auch eine
menge durch youtube bin viel unterwegs
reise viel und wenn ich das mal
gegenüber stelle von von anderen leuten
so was was bei denen so geht ist das
schon echt richtig cool und man kann
echt verdammt zufrieden und glücklich
sein was alles möglich ist
und ja also ich bin auf jeden fall
zufrieden
die frage hast du dein ziel erreicht ich
jetzt merke ich die ziele also ich mach
einfach also wie sagt man immer glück
ist erwartung dass diese formel glückes
erwartungen
also irgendwie realität über erwartungen
oder so was also ja deshalb setze mir
keine ziele wald und wenn ich immer
zufrieden mit dem was kommen auch gut
willst du mit einem fan der korrekt ist
was aufnehmen oder mal über ts quatschen
also grundsätzlich habe ich nichts
dagegen nur also wenn ich noch eine ts
bin und der leute treffe dann habe ich
auch mit ich bin wirklich verdammt
selten auf ts und ich gehe jetzt auch
nicht extra dafür auf dem t es aber so
an sich rede ich natürlich mit leuten
wenn ich die wenn ich treffe oder sowas
und aufnehmen ist immer so eine sache
weil wenn man hinten macht dann wollen
es wieder alle und dann ist man ein
arschloch wenn man es nicht mit allen
macht was irgendwie ist es verdammt
kompliziert wenn man das letzte format
macht was sich aber auch als mega
kompliziert herausgestellte bei dem tod
gerettet werden
dann ist das noch komplizierter und ja
also ich glaube
nein so was also ts quatschen ja klar
aber so ihm jetzt muss ich nach diesem
video schreiben dann war schon wieder
200 leute elcom auf den ts sein mandat
an das kann natürlich nicht machen also
wenn das ist sowas muss sich halt alles
ergeben man trifft sich dann mal man
sieht sich mal sowas und dann ergibt
sich das aber so einfach mit komplett
unbekannten kompliziert interessante
sache fans der eben no go oder letzte
mittel greift die lena sehr cool
formuliert die frage wer sägt
situationsbezogen person also kann man
nicht ausschalten so fans denken geht
absolut nicht klar aber wenn es so
jemand so richtig so richtig heftiger
fan ist dann ist das schon komisch
irgendwie weil die sehen ja dann die
sind dann vielleicht so vernarrt oder so
in wie du dich gibst und zu aber ich
vorher auch schon gesagt habe das ist ja
nicht 100 prozent also wenn ich dann mit
meinen freunden reden diese gewissen den
videos teilweise viel viel reflektierter
und sonst was also ist weil ich wirklich
so kopf bin ich in wirklichkeit unter
meinem ein gehörte das immer so und mir
selbst fällt das auch nicht aufarbeiten
scheint schalte ich auch so umso
zwischen video und so aber ja also
grundsätzlich würde ich nicht nein sagen
aber das ist schon eine komplizierte
sache
wie groß bist du hashtag ich frag markt
ist also ich bin 1 meter 90 so um den
dreh ich habe meine person steht 190 ist
herein und
zu mittag gehende ungefähr ich wieder
geldkarte hersteller ich frag mal auf
was freust du dich moment in richtung
musik so richtig also januar soll cd ich
freue mich schon wieder auf so ein
bisschen asi deutschrap auf das neue
album von therapie bestimmten branche
und ich freue mich auch die aluminium ep
japan kommt und auf die titanplatten
letzte frage für heute von der werten
alea was wird ja am meisten von gestern
in erinnerung bleiben ich weiß gar nicht
es war an sich einfach ein cooler tag
werden es nichts besonderes gemacht oder
sowas
aber es war irgendwie schon besonders
weil sie mit dem erwachsenwerden sein
wird das wird irgendwie auch so gerade
für für die die mutter oder so wird das
emotionalen dann kriegt man so ganz
besonders ausgedrückt wie lebt man
jemanden woche ist und das ist schon
cool dann haben wir auch verdammt gut
gegessen und ich habe echte geschlecht
auch gleich wieder tun wäre ja auch hier
recht weit es aber das ist halt einfach
ein cooler tag gewesen wir haben auch so
gut gegessen habe meine freunde
getroffen ich meine familie getroffen
insgesamt ein cooler tag und dann würde
ich sagen dass von heute wollen wir die
nächste abtauchen